hello everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don Saucon now we are sitting
down with Spiro Scooby nice hello thank
you so much for joining thank you for
having it whoa I'm excited so we are
still at KO fest congress on the future
of engineering software
spiros is the former Deputy Minister of
Foreign Affairs of Greece he is also the
program director for the center of
sustainable development goals at the
University of Cambridge and that is
awesome I mean I am so excited to talk
about scuzz the UN and the sustainable
development goals in the UN have been so
important to me and now hearing that
there's other efforts in Europe that are
really focused around all this you've
been teaching me about the little review
system test that's been going on and see
how to use too much to say but let me
first of all say just for the record
that the center is a joint effort
between the University of Cambridge
University of Cambridge has a special
program on sustainability leadership and
I helped develop a joint program between
the University of Cambridge and the
European public law organization which
is an international body working on
governance and public law yes and I'm
directing this joint program and I was
not teaching you anything you seem to
know why stuff about STDs but for the
sake of those who are not very familiar
Lee I just say that in in September 2015
all the countries of the United Nations
which is quite an exceptional thing you
don't have things being voted by all the
countries of the UN came together and
decided that humanity has to move move
on and adopted 17 goals that are the
goals that will hopefully lead humanity
into sustainable development so no
poverty no famine and clean energy for
every education clean energy protection
of the oceans climate change agriculture
food you name it everything one of those
goals is number 17 actually is the last
one and it's about how we'll make it
happen by involving everyone yeah and
this is where governance comes in the
picture yeah
because unless you manage to find a way
to bring all the different sides of
human development together you will be
actually running like you know chasing
you're curious we say in my language in
your tail your teeth yeah
and so we establish the center because
we want to find ways to help both the
private sector and the public sector to
address those goals find ways to
implement them and we realize that it's
quite a hike on it's not an it is its
its most we're trying to get private
sector we're trying to get government
and then we're trying to get scientists
and technologists also work within this
pie and how do we get them all to work
together in Greece but then how is it
different for the Dominican Republic how
is it different for Taiwan you know it's
so much different across different parts
of the world and so and so how do we
create these systems and how do we maybe
make a toolset that can be available for
a country that's like I want to be
working on our sustainable development
goals and it's like oh this here's how
you get scientists and technologists
involved with the private sector with
the government so that's so important
I'll tell you a story short story about
how this Center was created back in 2015
if I remember 14:15 I was working with
the United Nations as an advisor and we
created what we call the Mediterranean
strategy for sustainable development so
25 countries are on the Mediterranean
decided that they wanted to have a
strategy a common strategy again getting
countries to agree around the meter and
in not pin and automatic thing and they
did develop this strategy it was voted
by all of them adopted then they had to
implement it and then they asked us to
find a way so that we would do a peer
review so that each country would be
reviewing the others and see how in fact
they in reality they do implement also
scores so we devised a strategy that we
call the simplified peer review
mechanism in which the central idea was
that no country would only be reviewed
so a country would review the others and
would be reviewed by us and the first
three countries you three and you'd get
reviewed by three no the three countries
that participate so the two are
reviewing the third
and it goes around so everyone is at the
same time reviewer and you will review
review to a new key reviewed by two by
two exactly and so the first three
countries that we did were also very
interesting geographically because we
had France very big g7 country we had
Morocco North Africa rich country with a
very forward-thinking leadership under
they give the King Mohammed the sixth
and Montenegro very small country that
came out of the dissolution of Mexico's
labia it was interesting we learned a
lot of things but the most interesting
thing that we saw was that no matter
what the size of the country or the
public administration they were facing
exactly the same problem and when I say
the size compared for example that in
France we had about twenty thousand
people working in the headquarters of
the Ministry of Environment and ecology
in Montenegro you had about 20 people so
the scale was very different and still
they were facing exactly the same
problem which was our policies our
sectoral so you have a policy for
agriculture you have a policy for
transportation you have a policy for
food policy for energy and so on and
there is no way you can get them to
cross refer what they're doing to work
together so we thought that if we cannot
find a way to improve the governance
between them and also how to involve the
private sector business as you said
technology science and everyday people
most of all there is no way we can
advance to the point of literally
implementing the SDGs we might implement
something which is good for the
environment or something which is good
for fisheries or something which is good
for transportation but across the board
it would not happen unless we find ways
to get them to work all together and
this is what we're focusing very much on
just to give you an example because the
structure of countries not only
governments countries as in their
economy and their society are structured
like this very often the public they the
legislation of countries does not allow
things to happen a different way so it's
very deeply rooted in for example the
constitution of a country so you have to
make very deep changes to
est geez be implemented and this is what
we are trying to focus on so as an
example let's let's say that we're in
France and we're observing the way that
they're working with transportation and
energy and food and education and then
they're there they're in these verticals
in the political system and so food
doesn't really talk to transportation in
the way that they're trying to solve the
food vertical doesn't talk to how
transportations trying to be solved in
the version of sustainability okay and
so then the idea is how do you get the
best principles from the food one that's
trying to solve the food sustainable
goal with the best principles of the
transportation one and maybe one can
take from the other one can take for the
other and then that's just France and
then you look at Montenegro and you say
well how were twenty people can we help
change and help them how can they take
principles for us and exactly you each
other okay and this just started 2017 -
yes this this was the agreement between
Cambridge and the European public law
organization happened in 2017 so now
we're setting up the whole program would
have very very positive uptake from
everyone that we speak with and now
we're trying to build the capacity of
all the system you know by by selecting
actually people globally who can come
and share their knowledge with those
that need it but it's not just sharing
their knowledge as we said before in a
different sectoral thing it's it's more
than this let me give you an example
which also will help you maybe
understand a bit why I am at coffees
because I have the technical person I
mean I have nothing to do with
technology when I came here I do think I
would understand anything those people
say actually but it was much much better
than that I took away so much
information and
inside from all that these people shared
here at coffees so take a city okay
let's take any city and when I say city
imagine that the prediction of the
United Nations by 2050 is that we will
have around 41 mega cities a mega city
is anything bigger than 10 million in
the in the meteor engine we have already
two or three of them one example is
Istanbul about 1520 million if I
remember right Cairo 25 million huge
cities now a city is not just an
addition of the buildings the roads the
bridges the parks the water
infrastructure the waste management know
that it's much more than that because it
is a living thing yeah it's a thing that
has its own life yes it has influx of
food and other resources it has things
that flow out it's huge I mean it's a
very very complicated thing now if you
try to address the problems of a city
and that's just one example in in
different sectors and say ok I will have
Allen deal with the roads and then I
would have a Sparrow's deal with the
buildings and then I will have Cristina
deal with water management eventually
all these people will not be able to
collaborate and the analogy I would give
is what we are discussing in the
beginning is if you try to build a human
body by design in each of the organs
separately from the other and then you
cluster them all together and try to
find the links to make them work it will
not work so you have from the outset to
start designing the organs or the
policies in the case of a city is the
genes in parallel so that they are made
in a way to communicate now this is
where technology comes in because when
you try to get them to communicate the
sheer quantity of information and
complexity you have to take into account
is so big that human brain cannot
respect it's too much too much
information it's impossible all of these
different parameters and all of these
uncertainties that you have if one thing
changes what happens with
everything else it's impossible for
humans to grasp and this is why humans
have devised the way of governance that
they have now which is you know vertical
and horizontal things so that we have a
way to manage it enter AI artificial
intelligence is becoming so strong that
it can help us analyze all of this draw
the conclusions on what works what
doesn't what are these synthetic and
analytical tools that we have to put in
place and in that sense becomes in my
view at least probably the best and only
partner that humanity has if it wants to
really be in a position to implement the
SDGs and this is what I'm taking away
from Kofi's I see that these people here
they understand very well how the tools
they develop can be so strong nowadays
and will be becoming much stronger
especially with the machine learning
processes that will allow all of these
analytical tools to learn as it goes
that it will be able to provide us with
with understanding the complexity of the
thing and then put in solutions that can
that can coordinate all of these things
that need to be happening at the same
time yeah I really love the analogy to
the human body because you can't just
work within the transportation vertical
or food vertical and then try and figure
out oh how do we sustainably do this
together you we got to build them from
the ground up together from the cell
level up from when you were evolved up
and so that makes a lot of sense of how
the human body functions and how the
sustainable development goals should
function because there are there are so
many ways that transportation is linked
with food that education is linked with
healthcare energy is linked with zero
emissions and how that's linked to food
development agriculture so this just
it's also linked together that it's you
can't we can't just unlink them and then
try and fix them and then try and relink
them exactly so I'm glad that that's
that you do that with a human body the
patient is dead that's what we're trying
to avoid yes yeah you mentioned that the
transportation in food it's very
interesting if you think that currently
about one-third of the global food
production is wasted it never reaches
people that need to eat it yes it's just
wasted because the transportation and
processing and storage and all that is
inefficient aesthetics this one you look
at it and if it can't pass like some
looking's has to me so one-third is
wasted and and if we have to deal with
the population growth by 2050 we'll have
around 9 billion people on the planet
yeah which means we have to to produce
about 60 percent more food now if we
manage to save the 1/3 that is is wasted
that means that probably it's doable
yeah if we don't yeah we have a problem
landfills are disgusting they are there
have you ever been to understand I am I
have been to the landfill it's really
[ __ ] bad it's probably one of the
worst things that humanity has done is
just made trash a normal part of our
lives exactly we just did garbage cans
there you throw it away you forget about
it because then later it gets taken to
the garbage dump
which then gets shipped off and buried
into land
and buried into land that is a
resolution right and you bury a thing
that these raw materials it is it is it
is wealth actually what you bury there
is wealth because you can produce energy
yes produce compost for producing food
just throw away your roma compost is
crazy there in San Francisco I don't
even think twice being in San Francisco
we all compost now so I'll tell you
something about San Francisco that I
love you know that San Francisco and the
Napa Valley produces some of the best
wine in the world you know where the the
fertilizers come from it's compost from
that stuff that would otherwise be
thrown away so you produce some of the
most tasteful and tasty sorry and and
wonderful wines in the world and lots of
value-added and money into that by
making good use of what otherwise would
be just waste and then you would let
other parts of the world where
composting is not being done people
don't care about it or even
you know biodegradable polymers or
something the plastic packaging that
comes on things is is currently takes
years and years to degrade versus one
that could only take a week or two weeks
to do great but the corporations and
shareholders have to be willing to
sacrifice a small small percentage of
the profit to use degradable packaging
but this is true if things stay the way
they are but we think that if we as we
said before we want to get policymaking
and in science to work together so that
AI and other science can yeah we've
talked about it can go into this process
and help there are two more very
important parts of that one is business
if we manage to go into the
implementation of the of the sustainable
development goals this is actually I
think that creates a lot of good
business good yeah jobs and all that so
the businesses that now would be
reluctant to change that because it
costs more if they go into the new model
that will have to establish they
actually developed new business and and
lots of people that are young the better
Millennials or Gen Z people will say
that oh look there's this new company
certainly if they you have to move in
that direction or you're fall behind
you know what Millennials actually it's
it's a very interesting case where they
do grasp the importance of going toward
sustainability and for example
Millennials of big family fans and so on
they do approach their investment
companies now and say we do not mind if
our returns on our capital are a bit
lower as long as they are sustainable
that's sorry because that means not only
that they're ok with themselves but they
investment they do is viable in the long
run yes and that shows human
intelligence age as fantastic so you
have the business development side of
things
which is great and I think that all of
the new technologies and all that must
be turned into new companies that will
create wealth that will create jobs that
will make people happy to work for what
they do rather than feeling bad because
the waste streams are bad or that third
point that I think is very important is
that we need to engage the younger
generation not only
but children yes part of that process
now yes we cannot wait until the tools
are ready and the strategies are already
and then we say okay come in guys and
you will do they have to be part of that
because they they think more positively
that's it and in different abstract open
ways and if the parents and the teachers
and the communities can help the young
kids care more about Kimble Kimble
Musk's initiative with the learning
gardens is really interesting st i love
that yeah hopefully we get some that in
europe soon
well we're actually we're now organizing
a very important conference in athens in
October 2018
what is that office and the conference
is organized by our Center in the
Economist how sweet let's say it's about
sustainability also and actually Kimball
is invited to speak all that I hope you
will make it we are in touch with him
have some good relations but you know
his program is like crazy and so if he
manages I want him to come and explain
exactly this yeah how you get the the
people that are generally interested or
can become generally interested in
especially younger generations to be
part of the effort you don't have to
convert them you just have to show them
that it's done and it's fun they take it
on their backs they start running yeah
yeah learning gardens are super fun you
just they're right out there they're
doing it as part of their daily
excitement and they're learning and
they're growing food and then they're
tasting it right there and and it's a
whole ecosystem of love and
understanding for the planet and I just
I'm really happy what is the conference
will be in October you said it's on the
1st and 2nd of October we are in a sense
we are very it is the sustainability
summit sustainability summit for
southeastern Europe and East Bay
Turanian and awesome the region
hopefully simulation can go and would
love to have you there we'd love to have
you there guys how did the president of
the Hellenic Republic has put it under
his auspices so he will be doing the
opening of the event which is great and
if you have the head of of a state yeah
putting so much attention into
sustainability it's good news yes and
we're
grateful that he chose to do that oh
yeah but also we're trying to get people
across the board I mean there will be a
couple of people that we had hunted here
at coffees and they will be speaking
about AI big data management and so on
we'll have a session about sustainable
finance because this is a very important
thing how finance is a driving force for
business can change the way that
business operates you were mentioning
that earlier it's sacrificing a little
bit of profits to invest into a
sustainable business rather than one
that's not that's so cool there was a
head of big very big company who's
saying that sustainability is not a case
of just doing your rightful thing for
society or the planet it's a matter of
survival of the company because in the
long run if you're not sustainable you
will be deleted by the system yes so you
know it's just self-preservation self
you know saving your own existence
actually it might be in sustainable and
that's very important we we try to focus
on the things that can really make a
difference and they are the issues that
are the agenda of tomorrow I think that
we cannot I don't remember who was who
said that
that we cannot just he keep on giving
all problems new names and think that
we're doing something about it you just
have to put down the agenda and say that
we have to move forward with us turn the
page and involve all of humanity in
trying to change that option be is a
very bad one I mean if we don't address
climate change we all know that it would
not end up well for the humans officials
address ethics or morality as a society
especially with AI and biowarfare and
all these very important yeah and that's
why I was just saying that in the
koffice conference that we have a chance
of turning AI into the best partner or
the only partner that humanity has if it
wants to go into the sustainable way yes
so let's try to focus on this rather
than using a in every other stupid
possible way that we've heard many
people you know giving warnings about
how to turn sour and all that I want
ask you about this before we move on how
does AI leverage machine learning on
data set in transportation or a data set
in the food vertical how do they how did
may I learn in those verticals and then
how would it are we talking about things
like when the farmer finishes growing
their batch of produce and then the AI
already knows that the vehicle should be
there at this day of the week and that
then at this time of the day and then it
shifts it to at the store and then from
the store then we're able to run data on
when the person comes and purchases that
item from the store and when they go
home and eat it and that way you know
that it's fresh and that it's and that
it's not one third of the food isn't
going to waste so is that kind of how
we're thinking about analyzing it's many
different ways one way is let me give
you a very practical example say that we
currently if you see how the food
distribution system goes is say we have
a farm and we produce I don't know one
ton of tomatoes then this thing we can
either sell door-to-door to our
neighborhood which is not a very big
scale model and it's not really a
sustainable thing if you want to scale
up or otherwise you have to go through
the Central Market sell it to the to the
big scale wholesalers and then they will
go into distribution and in this process
a lot of food will be wasted a lot of
energy will be wasted for moving all
these things around and everything and
we lose something which is very very
important which is called traceability
so the thing that we will buy to eat or
feed our children we do not really know
where it comes from what it has inside
know that yes one way that AI and new
technology can help is for example
blockchain so if you try to manage the
whole food stream through blockchain
that means that at every step of the way
there is some landmarking of what
happened when my food was produced and
then it also allows me to buy directly
from you because I cannot contact you
through this chain without having all
the intermediaries in the process this
saves a lot of money
chris is the quality and saves a lot of
wasted otherwise food so this is one way
that can happen another way is that if
you want to plan for your Agricultural
Policy as a country or a region or a
state it's very important to be able to
digest all the information of what is
happening with production to correlate
that for example with weather patterns
and weather predictions of what would
happen so you know when the supply of
food will be there and arrange it in
relation to demand for food so you do
not have the waste and all the things
that will not be purchased and will rot
on the on the show no it's gonna rain at
2 p.m. tomorrow you should make sure
your water system doesn't go off at
exactly and we have had the case like
this I met in in a fantastic program in
Australia called I know Vice we met a
couple of young scientists who were
devising a system of how irrigation for
for grape grapes for for wine production
should be done so that in water scarce
areas you do not waste water that's
simple and it's it was really a very
simple applet that they created with
some some technical appliances and it
was saving I don't know 20 30 percent of
the water that was going there also huge
yes huge so you see there are many ways
I mean you have AI coming into the the
policy perspective of things so you
integrate all the information you have
practical ways of making sure that the
flows of goods are happening in a way
that is much more sustainable and then
you have practical tools that help you
manage your resources in a much better
way so you don't waste water you don't
create waste that that would just go to
land houses were saying before I mean
it's it's endless and I think that this
is the beauty of it that that new
technologies create a whole new world of
possibilities that we can use for
turning the page for Humanity yes so
spirits do you think that moving forward
that will have both leveraging AI
across all these different verticals and
trying to have them talk to each other
like a human body would from its
birth form rather than trying to build
up first and then talk and then do you
think that this review system will be in
place as well so moving forward are we
going to have sustainability goals be
reviewed across countries and also
leveraging the angelus is that kind of
what we're saying is probably yes I mean
it's not a necessity to have the
cross-referencing but I think that
because we'll be hopefully working with
artificial intelligence there has to be
an iterative way of educating and
enriching the knowledge of the system
which is our best best partner so AI has
to keep on learning how this thing is
done if we don't do the reviewing we're
losing all the the feedback and
refitting all this knowledge into the
system I was yesterday discussing here
at coffees with somebody and we were
saying that there's a very interesting
difference between how technology is
developed because technology in most
cases has an incremental progress so you
know you have one thing and then
something else happens and all that
policy is not like this policy
development comes in very big chunks
they are monolithic who comes later is
there for the next 20 40 50 years and
one of the problems with policy is that
to this day humans do not have ways of
refeeding all of this knowledge
historical knowledge and this is why we
say that history repeats itself if we
could repeat all this knowledge of
humanity into history it would not be
repeating certain having you know one
war and then after so many years have
another war these stupid things that
happened with humanity so we're hoping
and I'm hoping that by actually doing
all this this review of what is
happening we will be able to learn along
with our tools our technological tools
to not do the same stupid thing again
yeah and actually lead to a very very
high rate of evolution of the human
species on the earth but with a much
lighter footprint on the earth
the same day ooh high-five to that
that's good yeah
and we're ready for that hockey stick of
human evolution we should be we better
be ready for it in information
technology should be advancing us faster
to get there and it has been but many
people talk about how in the 1950s there
were so many people saying that all
flying cars I right around the corner
and all these other kind of things and
you know why didn't we get there why
didn't we get there what were the
reasons why look I think you can always
look on the positive you know the half
empty half half-full bottle if you think
they the changes that happened in the
last two centuries you had a typography
you had television radio all the media
and all that they did lead also to a lot
of you know fake news and all that stuff
that we have and and over burdening
humanity with information all that but
at the same time the educational effect
that has is amazing
is amazing yeah I mean humans if you go
to three centuries but did not have one
increment or the ability now literacy
was way less so now if you choose to use
those tools in a stupid way of course
that would backfire on you and that's
why I'm saying and we are saying here
that it is up to us I mean what will
make of AI we design the tools it's
nobody else I mean they don't come from
from the sky we design the tools and if
we put an objective in designing those
tools to help those efforts that
humanity has to make to have a better
future we're doing the right thing if we
don't okay here's here's a good question
for ya
it kind of leads us down some of our
more simulation questions the question
is a lot of our efforts is about okay we
designed this tool this tool is a design
into the world but then the follow-up
question is what do the people use the
tool for mm-hmm
do people use genetic engineering to
create augmented intelligence or do we
create bio war weapons for bio warfare
so then the question becomes do we was
it was it doesn't we need to make some
objective code in the tool that prevents
people from making biowarfare
or is it have to do more with this inner
management this thing that's that's a
million dollar question what do you
think I think that humanity is not
inherently either stupid or bad I think
that that humanity has a self preserving
talent let's say or you know I think
yeah keeps it ticking and I believe that
we will see some of that stupid stuff
happening obviously I mean you cannot
help it because we we've seen it with
past technologies you see also the bad
part of that when we prevent more of the
bad from happening through inner
management or through the code or
through what I think it starts with
inner management yeah I think it starts
with what you have inside your your your
your your soul your your psyche as we
say in Greek you know it's a it comes
from from your own existence and what
you want to be at the end I mean if what
you want to be is creating mass
destruction systems then you're not
really a human person but I think that
when you're rewiring was off when you
were a kid something was wrong with your
love and your compassion whether it was
from parents or from community or
teachers or whatever happened that that
young opposed young ages but you see
it's it's it's a value system at the end
of the end at the end of the day it's a
value system because if your values are
about making humanity better then you
will be investing all of your efforts
and your work into that that positive
thing and that's the biggest challenge
for Humanity I mean we have to have the
right set of values there yeah and I
think discussions like those that will
have a Coface should and very often
we're actually about the value system
that is behind all that in many
different ways but at the end of the day
there was a lot of talk about you know
humanity and the values that we need to
serve
no one to me that was a very good
takeaway well Spiros okay let's say from
your perspective you have you have a
good amount of understanding about the
importance of these sustainable
development goals the importance of
humanity collaborating how do you see
Humanity working together in the next
decade or two
right now we have China has large day.i
budget Russia saying that or whoever
wins the AGI is gonna win everything so
how do you how do we work together what
are the steps we need to take to work
together
um I cannot predict how we will but I
can tell you how I propose that we would
put that into a permutation from our
side at least which is that we want to
work with with technology architects so
people that will be building the
programs and all that technology that
needs to be put in place to help them
understand what are the big questions
and then they can quantify it they can
put in a program the uncertainty
parameters they can put in a program how
you will be able to crunch all this data
to produce something useful and the
point here is that if we expect the
machines to help us ask the right
questions we are wrong the questions
have to be put there by humans as much
the architects plus big question exile
of humanity put the questions and
technology does the processing because
if you must cannot do it and should not
do it
so if you blend those two together and
you turn to the audience's that are as
we said the children the investments
community the business the politicians
but then you start building something
that is quite different from all the
governance system that we had in the
world so far yeah so you actually create
the new era for Humanity and probably it
sounds a little bit you know dreamy and
in too visionary but I think that we
have to try exactly yeah who do we have
to blame if we don't try it we can
imagine we should try to do it of course
and I think I think we sell ourselves
short so much so many times we say that
it's not not possible ideal governance
systems not possible we haven't tried we
haven't tried these sorts of potentially
utopia doesn't mean utopia for everybody
in one way utopia can mean for you one
utopia for me different utopia but some
maybe some basic rules like we shouldn't
kill each other okay great we agree
awesome and so how do you get the
scientists working with the business
working with the politicians working
with technologists I love the idea of
the of a governance system working on
those principles and putting the
technology architects with the big
questions a lot of what we do on this
show is the big question is and I love
that that's why I wanted to be here and
thank you very much for having me but we
love music I think that I don't know how
it happened really that all of the
countries of the world agreed to have
the STDs in place
I mean sometimes jokingly I say that
probably they didn't know what they were
voting for they had not totally
understood but in it's a joke but I
think that we have a unique opportunity
in the history of humankind because we
now have an agreement around this
visionary utopic if you like thing but
it's there I mean it's agreed by the UN
never before in the history of humanity
did you have that so if we don't have it
now and we don't start working that it's
it's a wasted opportunity and I for one
am not prepared to waste an opportunity
like that because you know everybody
loves her kids
yeah and that's why we should be doing
it yeah that's it yeah cuz you want to
pass down a beautiful world to the next
generations one yes one that has less
problems one that has more flourishing
over and over again every generation
should be making it better look one
thing that we we see very often now is
that you have Millennials and if our
younger generations now that are very
different from how we were they have a
different concept about what work is
about what their objective should be and
all that and this is not happening by
accident and it's happening because the
system's value has changed the world
and they do not exactly see where they
will fit so I think that we don't just
want to give them a better world but we
want to involve them with all of this
question marks that they have around
them in the way they see the world to be
the ones that will drive this process
yeah they they can start now and it
would just you know put the tools down
there like parents used to do when were
kids it would give us the Legos and
we'll just sit there and create
something and a little bit of guidance
but then it's it's them that do it
themselves yeah this is what we should
be doing just build the tools and then
let them play with the proper guidance
and change the world yeah I love it I
love it I feel like we're this is
exactly what we're on and I have so many
conversations about kids and the
importance of having kids be why why
these kids suggested that they may be a
kid oh my English is not that good I
didn't even know that no okay children
children of the children of the earth
and so we we have so many conversations
about children and the importance of
children retaining the sort of creative
loving characters that they do from
birth into the world and you know
Picasso talked about it as well to
retain those childlike characteristics
through adulthood it's so important
which i think is very important also for
another reason there is so much talk
that you know with AI and automation and
robotics and all that coming through
humans will be out of a job I hope be
able to do anything now I'll be children
again as we said before and the spinach
will just fly in and land on my plate
and I know it's okay I don't have
anything I guess as long as I know where
the spinach is coming from and if it's
good but we said before that the
artificial intelligence will be
crunching the data and providing the
answers but humans have the intuition
and
and talent and you know the the the
humor part of the equation to ask the
right question so I think that we should
also be making sure that all of these
talents that children will have need to
be amplified as much as possible because
this is the only thing that will protect
humanity from losing its own creativity
in possibility to be working because
working is something that defines people
defines humans and it would be a very
bad thing I believe to think that you
can have a society without work because
yes we'll be doing everything so yeah
but work has to be around intuition
about talent about I mean music and
painting will never be done by machines
I think music in the sense already know
done by machines but in the sense of you
listen to it we have we had someone on
earth show that made a I yes on grating
AI and it was it was pretty good it was
good yeah it's good but this is the
thing is if you look at the the future
of humanity as a as somebody needs to be
in the driver's seat of the AI I wonder
who's gonna be in the driver's seat of
the AI and I think there's many people
here that we've talked to as well that
are that are very aware of what's going
on around the world with things like IP
theft from China and things like what is
the reason why that is happening is it
just for the horizontal globalization or
is it so that there can be a vertical
spike in terms of one country and so
that way there can be in this sort of a
domineering growing force so I I
frequently question what's actually
going to happen with wealth inequality
with the benevolence of the people that
are the technology architects I like how
you said that they have to be paired at
the big questions but then they also
have to be paired with inner management
because the technology architects and
the people posing these big questions
have to be very grounded into ecology
and into the harmony of all the plants
most species on this planet as one any
other things that you said like equity
equality sorry between humans and
respect of human values and all that
this is part of stainability you cannot
have one without the other because it
leads to inequalities it and to
imbalances that at the end of the day
will turn over the whole thing the whole
construct I I've very think about this a
lot because there are I frequently can
speak with people that are both liberal
and conservative people because I really
enjoy but they're both of their
respective circles and and I speak with
free-thinking a lot and so because I go
through all these waves I see that
conservatives have a tendency to think
that it's okay and this is a tendency
but have a tendency to think that it's
totally okay to speciate as it's totally
okay for there to be a hyper rich and
for there to be a hyper poor and that
for for the hyper rich to advance as the
better species and the liberals tend to
again tendency tend to think that that
that's not okay and that it's important
that we funnel a lots of our resources
into though bringing the poor up and
actualizing them and try and lift rising
tide all boats for sure all no matter
what and so I that thought process for
me is very important because we're
approaching it in these next couple of
decades and I'm very hesitant to be I
want to be a voice of reason of concerns
of conversation around the planet I
think the only way one can answer such
big questions is by being very pragmatic
I would think and I would I would vouch
for the option that says I'm not taking
any side because I am trying not to be
politicized in that because it's more
important than just politics but I think
that if you manage to empower humanity
as a whole in the sense of having good
health good quality and all that that
means that you have a much better
control of what human
do in terms of population growth you
know population growth is not happening
at crazy numbers where you have good
education or good health it's happening
in the places that do not have good
education or good health so if you want
to contain population growth by by
people wanting to be part of the
containment then you have to provide the
means if you want to have people better
their livelihoods for the benefit of all
they have to create more value added and
this is by training by providing the
tools by also investing in those
societies so I think that it is to the
benefit of humanity as a whole
even of those that want to be on the
other you know one or two or three
percent with a very very big world
because it would always be that and
there's nothing wrong with that really I
mean yeah some people will be super rich
fine
yeah it's not a problem with me yeah but
it doesn't mean that this has to go step
on on a layer of misery of humanity
because that actually will trickle up it
will trickle up and there will be some
sort of problem that arises from it and
but personally we all live in the same
planet we all do and it's all a shared
ecosystem and so this is why even though
there's no problem with somebody being
hyper rich I I do think there begins to
be a problem when that person is trying
to buy as much land as possible by as
many boats and watches and all these
materialistic possessions as possible so
they can do things like read seek or do
things like try and be conspicuous with
their consumption and stuff like that
because those things actually don't
advance your soul yeah
they don't advance your soul no that's
very important yeah that's hugely
important because I think that humanity
and humans are losing their their own
debt you know there is a no being yeah
if if all you are about is the make of
your shoes and how many pairs of shoes
you have and how big is your boat and
how big is my boat yeah there are other
values I mean if you take if you take
two children that are you know very
young and they have not had time to be
influenced by all that and one of them
comes from a mega rich family and the
other one comes from a family of
immigrants that are dirt poor and they
don't have any way
just let them play together yes they
will never speak about their parents
yachts yeah they only find out the other
qualities not yeah and if maybe the
young one would be like we have you know
oh what's about oboe this you want to
come look at exactly exactly yeah yeah
instead of having a big walls oh these
are the values you have to build up yes
I'm glad we touched on that how about we
touch a little bit on do you think we're
alone in the cosmos oh that's that's a
good question
look I have been thinking about that
quite a lot you know I'm I'm Greek so
philosophies by DNA but I think that
there is no reason why we would be alone
at the cosmos I'm not talking about the
physical I'm talking really really
practical practically whether there are
other creatures in the universe I think
that there is no reason why we should be
the only living thing on that but then
again I mean this is a discussion that
can take many different ways because
scientists say that there might not be
just one universe but many parallel
universe right so there you have it I
mean again the uncertainty levels go
very high but you know we have a saying
in my country that before you start
looking what's happening with the others
try to put your own house in order
this is what you should focus on I love
that one that's been a key in our lives
with Tony Robbins with Jordan Peterson
with these figures that speak about
cleaning your own room taking care of
yourself Swami
Ananda inner management spirituality
that kind of a thing I'm glad that
that's so what do you think that there
are advanced civilizations that maybe
roam the cosmos and colonize the cosmos
do you think that that already exists
why not why not I mean I I cannot say
that there are or not because I should
know something about it and on a
cognitive level I don't but on a
probability level why not I mean I'm not
so selfish to think that you know the
evolution of of time and space decided
that it will only wanted to create Allen
and Spiros you know
exactly and only this earth exactly the
surface but then again you know the best
thing we can do is to try to be really
evolved species because if and when if
nothing exists and when they decides to
come our way we better be a very volt
thing if they're revolting yes otherwise
I mean it would be the other dog with
that thing yeah you don't want to be
that will be their food yeah yeah
probably the evolved we should do our
best to be as evolved of a species as
possible do you think we're in a
computer simulation no you think this is
base reality no this is base reality I
don't think we're computer simulation I
don't think that we are dreaming
somebody's Minds whine sorry why why do
you think that um yeah that's that's a
good question I think this is this is a
bit ago istic actually I think because
we have all these feelings that we share
among us and this cannot just exist in a
dream you know a dream is a thing that
takes a very little bit of time and it
can be interrupted and start and stop in
any time I think that humanity has so
much richness in in everything carries
with it that it would be very demeaning
for it to think that you can just exist
in somebody's dream or somebody's one
thing that that's on the contrary I have
been contemplating with very much it
started by reading a book by Isaac
Asimov long time ago is that the
evolution of humans could at one point
go in a direction where we remain humans
in our souls very humans but we are less
and less attached to the physical part
of human being definitely which is
fantastic digital consciousness exactly
well it's so digital that's that's my
thing I mean you become a very conscious
thing but you become mostly unrelated to
your physical body which you need less
and less and less because what matters
in humanities yes what we think yeah and
that good eventually after I don't know
many millions of years become the
evolution of humanity to be less related
to the material part and that would
allow of course humanity to expand in
the rest of the universe yeah because
you don't have to carry your physical
part with you you just carry the the
mind oh I'm so excited for my soul to
just be able to go and just like have 25
more senses that I'm sensing the
universe with at one at one time and
dimensions in dimensions do you what do
you think the most beautiful thing in
the world
um I think it's my daughter's but the
most beautiful thing in the world is I
think it's love it's it's really
unbelievably strong this thing and I
think also it's creativity if what you
feel you know the thing that gets you
from your guts and drives you even if
you're down and out and if you don't
have the means and everything and you
feel the push of creativity inside you
and you pick up yourself and go on for
it again this is unbelievable the
strength that gives you and I think this
is what has helped humanity come up from
from its shambles every time and I think
it's it's magic awesome I love it
spirits thank you so much for joining us
I really enjoyed that such a pleasure
yeah it's super fun I'm really happy you
had a good time I hope that maybe if it
works out that we can come out but I
will send you the information yeah we'll
send you an invitation and we'd like you
to come and cover the event we would
love have very interesting people there
you can get interviews from all of them
and we may not know the president of
there but I would love that because you
know you share what you do with a lot of
young people and I really care about
what young people think and if there's
any feedback that we should be sharing
after that once you air your program
I'll be very happy to take into town
yeah I think that we do exactly thank
you so much thank you yeah
for all of your thoughts especially
around sustainability and being a voice
for reason around that around the world
that's very true
so for us moving forward guys at home
ladies at home two guys had a good time
please give us a like comment subscribe
share the content with other people it's
really important for us to share the
message especially a sustainability talk
to each other about it how can we move
forward how can we provide a better
world for our kids and their kids and
keep moving on and evolve more as a
species
you heard what Spiro said if you want to
become a patron and help us get to his
conference and help us pay for our rent
and all these important costs that we
have joined us on patreon.com force life
simulation series you get great
exclusive benefits big shout out to co
fats for having us big shout out to Ron
Vargas our producing partner thank you
so much everyone for tuning in and we'll
see you guys soon